el presidente vlodimir selenski llegó
aquí a la palacio del Eliseo para esta
cena de trabajo que tiene con el
presidente macron una cena y una visita
que en realidad solamente Fueron
confirmadas por el palacio del Liceo A
última hora aquí en a París bola de
mirza lensky llegó acompañado por una
comitiva en la que había algunos
militares y sobre todo durante esta cena
en la que se va a hablar de estrategia
Por una parte de las necesidades también
en cuanto a material militar Y también
necesidades humanitarias para Ucrania
tras más de un año de guerra con Rusia
les decía que también se va a hablar de
estrategias estrategia frente a esta
contraofensiva de primavera que debe
comenzar en los próximos días en las
próximas semanas o presidentes que ha
querido ser bastante diligente Y sobre
todo poder contar con todo el material
militar que necesita para esta
contraofensiva y sobre todo De esta
manera evitar la pérdida de Vidas
humanas que lo que necesita son sobre
todo más más armas en especial armas y
misiles de largo alcance para contra
ofensiva además de esto se espera hablar
de ese plan de paz que él propuso el año
pasado un plan de paz que consiste en
diez puntos Y eso también pues es la
idea de hablar ya de que esta sí es ya
va a comenzar la fase final de esta
guerra como dice el presidente ucraniano
Pues también se comience a pensar en lo
que será el después y en el regreso de
la paz al territorio europeo después de
esta cena se sabe que es el esquí va a
pasar la noche aquí en la capital a
francesa pero por razones de seguridad
claramente no sabemos si el día de
mañana Él regresará a Ucrania o si por
el contrario continuará con su gira
Europea